when we think of the risk of concussions
in athletes sports like football and
hockey often come to mind but
researchers have also been focusing on a
different sport how about this soccer
mild but repetitive hits to the head not
necessarily concussions can be risked
for the brain injury known as cte our
chief medical correspondent that's dr
john lapook has been looking into the
growing concerns about cte and soccer a
game played by an estimated 13 million
american children including vlad's
nephew we just learned first on cbs
mornings john interviewed retired u.s
soccer star bruce murray about his
growing fears for his health john good
morning most people don't think about
sarcasm no that's true good morning gail
cte is a stealth disease there's no cure
and it can only be diagnosed after death
symptoms include trouble with memory
problems organizing and planning simple
activities and changes in behavior such
as lack of motivation or having a short
temper today we're showing you the
uncertainty for a former elite player
who's now experiencing changes in his
memory
swinging
in 1990 crews marry the scorer bruce
murray was at the top of his game murray
with a header yes murray was a star at
clemson it was time for the bruce murray
show again before playing forward for
team usa it's the greatest feeling to be
able to travel the world and do what we
did murray nice run by bruce as he moved
into professional soccer murray
continued his reputation for being
fearless his aggressive play sometimes
left him seeing stars
how did those concussions generally
happen i was playing for the us and
saudi arabia and one of the saudi
players came right through and his knee
caught me in the head i was on my hands
and knees trying to find where my
equilibrium was but for the next six
weeks to a month i would go places and
not know why i was there back then they
would just say you got your bell rung
you heard that expression oh yeah yeah
get back out there or be tough murray
stayed tough through multiple
concussions and collisions he retired in
1995 at age 29. what made you finally
hang up your sneakers i was suffering
from post-concussion lack of sleep and i
have a hard time with light headaches my
body just felt like beaten up where do
you want to go for four years right when
we visited murray and his family in
maryland two years ago he was troubled
by recent lapses in memory so how's your
airplane coming there buddy including
one that left him especially shaken my
wife and my son and i were at the store
and i was in the car and they came out
and they came to the car and i said i
said oh sorry ma'am
do you need to get by and then
she kind of like looked at me like what
were you are you okay and then i was
like oh oh wait a second that's you
that you was the woman he had married
eight years earlier lynn murray when
bruce looked at you and didn't recognize
you
what was that like for you
it was shocking
it told me a lot
you know
i'm realizing now
that we don't have
the future that we were hoping for
so
it's the uncertainty
yeah good job kelly because of bruce's
history of concussions the murrays
reached out to boston university's
center for chronic traumatic
encephalopathy or cte the issue is the
repetitive hits that the players take dr
anne mckee is the center's director and
believes concussions are not the only
cause of cte i think there's been such
an emphasis on concussion in these
contact sports it's the hits that are
asymptomatic that the player plays right
through and over time those injuries
accumulate and lead to a high risk for
cte murray recalls heading the ball up
to 20 times a day during practice drills
but the balls were coming in at full
pace and you're just trying to get a
piece of it and get it in the net and
with your head oh yeah and many times
you would stagger back to the line and
your teammate would be like man that
looked terrible you okay you're like nah
yeah i'm fine i'm fine back then nobody
was saying hey you know maybe this is a
problem nobody said that yeah since cte
can only be diagnosed after death the bu
researchers scanned murray's head for
clues and they found one
his brain tissue seen here in gray had
atrophied or shrunk
compare that with this normal scan where
the gray brain tissue fills much of the
skull
do you think that heading should be
allowed in soccer there's an argument
for taking heading out of soccer those
balls are coming from a great distance
at a tremendous velocity and that
impacts the head and leads to these
injuries later on u.s soccer which
governs the sport from kindergarten
through the elite level has extensive
concussion protocols
and it bans or limits headers in
children 13 and younger but when it
comes to sub-concussive hits in older
players u.s soccer told cbs news it is
awaiting more research
the organization declined our request
for an on-camera interview think about
some of the military cases dr mckee has
examined the brains of hundreds of
deceased veterans and athletes including
football player aaron hernandez who died
by suicide while serving a life sentence
for murder
she thinks more needs to be done to
protect athletes of all ages is the
damage that you see in football similar
to the damage you've been seeing with
soccer yeah the changes look identical
whether they played rugby ice hockey
football or soccer it's the same
repetitive hits to the head we meet
again when we checked with bruce and
lynn murray recently they told us his
condition appears to be stable but he
still struggles with memory focus and
balance good go with pace with pace
excellent excellent good work good work
he still enjoys coaching youth sucker
good come find me come on come on come
find me there you go but believes the
sport he loves may need changes to make
it safer for everyone i think u.s soccer
needs to address this it's called
football all around the world good what
if you rewrote the rules do you have to
head the ball
you know other former players were also
concerned about possible long-term
effects of head trauma three years ago
we interviewed michelle akers and her
former teammate and soccer standout
brandi chastain both women have pledged
to donate their brains to science when
they die and to spread awareness of cte
while they are living
i've had more than a handful of
concussions so i know what it's like for
the viewer at home
may
wonder what it is like just imagine
sitting in your house at night and you
have a power outage
that's your mind goes dark
just like that
body goes limp you don't know what's
going on and then you come to
and the last thing you remember could be
30 seconds it could be a minute right it
really
varies depending on how severe the
concussion was but this is an issue that
these kids are dealing with and then
they become high school collegiate and
professional athletes which is
compounding these concussions year after
year yeah and of course the big problem
and dr mckee pointed that out is there's
no way of diagnosing it right now except
after death looking at the brain so
they're looking at ways of diagnosing it
before death so with scans with blood
tests with uh spinal fluid analysis and
if you can do that then maybe you can
start following kids who's at risk and
if they're at risk is there a way of
preventing
these injuries and and maybe even do a
trial to see what can we do to intervene
to stop it but this whole issue of the
sub-concussive hits needs much more
exploration i'm sure the picture you
showed was kind of jarring
showed of his brain thank you john
tomorrow on cbs mornings john's coming
back he'll have part two of this
investigation the family of former mls
player scott vermillion talks to him
about the clues
to cte that they learned about after his
death at age 44. we'll be right back